Some interesting discussions I spotted this
morning on the David Pakman show.
Subrata, now, you may or may not be participating
in this sub Reddit.
We have nearly 30000 of our viewers and listeners
subscribed to our sub Reddit.
This is free.
I'm selling you nothing.
You can join the discussion at David Pakman
dot com slash Reddit.
One interesting post points out that the CEO
of right wing social media platform Parler
has been fired.
And this is a wacky story.
The trials and tribulations of parler sound
like they would make a good sort of like a
for limited run dramatization on Netflix and
a Netflix original Now Parler, which was briefly
offline after the riotous mob stormed the
capital.
They now have fired their CEO.
John Matosi says he was removed as the chief
executive.
He didn't cite a reason, but apparently there
has been significant dispute within parler
as to how far they are going to take their
so-called commitment to free speech and open
dialog.
And it's an absolute and total mess over at
Parler, a comedy of errors.
And who knows what the future of that platform
holds.
I did sign up the CEO.
This is the guy who at one point said if any
prominent leftist with over one hundred thousand
Twitter followers signs up, we'll give him
20 grand.
I said I would take 20 grand or I'm not going
to turn that down.
Signed up and repeatedly notified John Mazzei
that I'm here and I've got one at the time,
hundred and twenty hundred and thirty thousand
Twitter followers.
Let me know how you want to send me the twenty
K and shockingly, I never heard back.
Also, another post from The David Pakman Show
sub Reddit, an article about Canada listing
the proud boys movement as a terrorist group.
Indeed they are.
Canada has announced that the proud boys and
twelve other groups are going to be designated
as terrorist organizations.
Some of these other groups we've mentioned
on the show before, they include these are
radical right groups like the Adam Washington
division and many others whose names are even
even more obscure.
Yeah, Canada is not messing around here.
They are moving forward powerfully and rapidly
with getting some of these groups listed as
terrorist groups.
Now, I lack enough of an understanding of
Canadian law to understand exactly what the
legal repercussions of this are.
But my instinct is that the reason Canada
would do this is not just sociological, but
that there are law enforcement reasons to
do this as well in terms of prosecutorial
discretion or abilities when it comes to dealing
with such groups, although it would take a
Canadian legal expert to tell me more about
it, join the discussion at David Pakman Dotcom,
read it.
Like I mentioned, almost 30000 of our viewers
and listeners regularly participating on The
David Pakman Show Subrata.
There are moderators.
So we don't allow bullying, we don't allow
doxxing or any of that stuff.
So join the party.
David Pakman, Dotcom, Reddit.